Welcome to Lee's Detective Agency.
We accept every manner of requests
and will do our best to meet your needs
in goods delivery, pickup,
infiltration, investigation,
arbitration, and conflict resolution.
We strive to serve you better.
We can solve *anything* in Lungmen.
And certainly,
except for detective work
because that's police business...
Please don't expect this to be a detective show.
The day just ended for someone.
And the day just started for somebody.
In empty streets I walked about
Confessing my boredom out loud.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
A Lapping of Waves
I'll never finish my thesis.
Hi!
You shouldn't study during an outing, you know.
The boss wants us to move something.
Can I take a photo of myself with your new ride?
Where did you get all this money? You even invited us to the beach.
I hope you didn't borrow from loan sharks. They're dangerous.
I'm doing better than you think.
Lee's DA made some money this year.
I paid off my debts and bought a new car.
I planned this outing to thank you all.
You're the most generous boss ever!
So get moving and carry my stuff.
Well, the holiday is great.
We'll head out to the ocean to do some surfing. All expenses will be...
Is that true?
Oooh. What happened, boss?
Has spring returned to the withered branch?
The old tree has blossomed once more.
And something stirs deep inside.
Go, Uncle Lee!
Be the eligible bachelor that you always wanted to be!
I'm just appreciating beauty.
It's a noble pursuit in its own right.
I finally submitted my thesis! Let's play ball!
Be careful and don't hurt anyone.
Alright.
Not interested.
I'm going swimming.
Mmm.
Let's go!
Try to play nice.
Come get some!
What did you drink?
Aak's special functional sports drink.
BOSS!
Bad news for you.
Of course, you can keep appreciating that married beauty of yours.
(There, there. Come on.)
You got lucky!
(Alright, you are fine now.)
(Go have fun!)
BOSS!
We got a situation.
Mom! MOM! *Gurgling*
MOM!
Oh! Thank goodness!
The beach is closing.
Please pack your belongings
and leave ASAP.
Starfishman saved me!
I...
I'm Starfishman.
Lee?
Ah, how long has it been?
Shao.
Thank you.
Fate allowed us to meet again.
We haven't seen each other for over 20 years.
Yeah.
How are you doing?
Shao, we should leave soon.
Okay.
Say goodbye to Starfishman.
Bye, Starfishman!
Bye!
Your drink messed me up again!
Look, I'm sorry, okay.
Once we head back, I'll be tossing out your lousy stuff.
Well, you might need it again in the future.
Simmer down, people. We'll talk about this when we get back.
This request is confidential and completed under my meticulous arrangements.
Feel free to take the rewards for DA's team building.
You're welcome.
To be continued...